hey it is a much better day for baseball
today the sky is blue the sun is out
it's daytime baseball dallas caico going
to mount he's in search of his fourth
win this is 11th start
when he's right the left side of the
infield is going to pick up a lot of
ground balls and he's hoping to do that
against the orioles historically it's
about two-thirds of the time where the
orioles hit the ball on the ground
against him and if that happens it's
going to be a successful day
3-2 is on the ground
jose at first has the first out of
today's double-header day of baseball
and that's exactly what keiko wants but
he gets the lefty mullins and here's
switch hitting freddie galvez
one strike pitch he swings and smacks
this one a deep left field back goes on
to the track and it's into the seats
make it two runs for freddie galvez
produced in this series as he leaves the
ballpark this time hitting from the
right side and gives the orioles a
one-nothing lead over the white sox in
this first inning it's home run number
eight of the year for freddie galvez
we said bright sunny about 57 degrees in
chicago i would imagine the wind is
blowing out this ball sails
out of here matt harvey trying to win
for the fourth time era inflated last
four seven six six the last four starts
tim anderson bobblehead day at the
ballpark
and a little guy very excited to be one
of the first 10 000
fans in the park look look what i got
tim anderson lights his first pitch up
welcome back tim
he's on his way to second base and this
is a leadoff double you said one might
not do it stoney i'm sensing that you
might be right i'm pretty much thinking
this is going to be an offensive day for
our socks two on
one out for abreu perfect situation you
want it to be
your biggest run producer
because he's got 40 of them and a couple
men on in the first inning
into center field he does it again on
two strikes
tim's coming home that lead didn't last
long for the birds 1-1
[Applause]
when you need the big runs driven in
jose abreu is your man now by the way
the crowd's reacting to 3-0 to mercedes
i believe we got some smart baseball
fans in this ballpark this is fun
three-and-oh to mercedes
oh i took a rip and he fouled it away
well i can now that's the thing
3-1 is hit in the air to right
backpedaling is santander he'll make the
catch moncado will tag and make third
and they will be at the corners with two
outs
pitch number 10 on the way and he struck
him out swinging so harvey wins that
battle second year oriole ryan mount
castle who had a very nice offensive
year in that 60 game season last year
three and two cold strike three on the
inside
corners
edge vicinity
and here's a special moment mom kristen
his girlfriend his friends his
girlfriend's emily and here's tyler
nevin grew up in a baseball family his
dad phil now the yankee third base coach
launches it down the right field line
it's in the corner it's a fair ball and
it caroms over the fence for a ground
rule double how about that for a first
major league hit it's a double for nevin
which he smokes down the line his family
and friends going crazy in the seats
welcome to the big links tyler nevin
announcing his presence right out of the
gate
check swing on a low one but he went too
far
tichel strikes out mckenna when you walk
a lead off hitter ahead of moncada abreu
mercedes and possibly lamb
you might have some difficulties in that
inning rondale at first three and two
that is in it's ball four harvey's walk
to pair in the third inning
and the man responsible for the lone sox
run coming to bat jose brave
look this is the inning where you want
to get
in the dirt bouncing away from severino
and the sox will take a couple of bases
and now there's fish in a barrel out
there for jose with a productive out
jose right side that gets through
pass to diving nevin tour on the way
home
jose does it again with two strikes
and it's 3-1 in the third
an rbi dispenser wearing number 79.
i know it's pretty early to put anybody
on first base via the intentional walk
but
for the sox
if there's a man to pitch around it's
the man who just shot that one into
right field he's driven in all three
runs 3-1 chicago bottom of the third
game one of a double-header jake lamb
now the batter
1-2
this ball is crushed by lamb deep right
field and bring him home 5-1
another left-handed meteor off of harvey
that one may have ended up in harvey
it's 5-1
in the third look everybody can look at
the numbers they're right there and
against left-handers matt harvey has had
a tremendous amount of difficulty
and jake lamb
and boy the left-handers love fastballs
that are thigh high outer third
especially deadpool hitters and it'll
bring up michael franco the third
baseman 5-1 white sox top of the fourth
and jeff we're in chicago so how did
harry say it let's get some runs this
breaking ball is in the air
deep center field garcia back still back
he leaps and that baby's gone
a solo homer from michael franco
and it's a 5-2 game
home run number five for franco
that one hits a dead center
and now the orioles trail by only three
here in the fourth
he hits this one to right field chasing
his lamb and he won't get it it's gonna
fall in for a base hit and rattle around
the corner mount castle thinking three
he rounds second he's going for third
and he will make it with a slide
one one pitch
that should get him home anderson takes
a look but he'll get the out at first in
the orioles lead
yeah tony larussa says i'll give you the
run again it's a shorter game
probably you know it's probably a game
where if it was nine innings he may have
brought the infield in
ray galves digs in from the right side
against dallas kykel freddy hit a home
run back in the first
that's it well
way back has he got another one back to
the wall it's gone
second homer of the game for freddie
galvez one man wrecking crew
two solo shots and the orioles are
within one
when they uh
acquired freddie galvez we look you know
funny home runs one year 23 another year
so he's got some pop and here it is left
left match up lamb with a two run homer
is last time at the back
lamp squared it up pretty well into
right field jake lamb on a 3-1 slider
deposits a base hit and right good stuff
today from jake lamp now billy's going
to come off the bench and pinch run
now it gets away and there goes billy
he'll take second base
and now laurie garcia who's not the
biggest slugger in the world if he gets
you a single you get a run
runner at second two down 3-0 is high
ball four to bring up madrigal
the one-two
and this one's it slowly back to the
mound scott off the mound throws to
first base and he pitches out of it
tanner scott
it looked like it was coming undone but
he keeps it together and he keeps it a
one-run game so anderson at first base
moncada will bat for the fourth time
oh boy
johan sends it way out of here
oh cannon fire seven to four
you may want to go replay the first
inning because my partner may have said
that's going to happen well look when he
starts taking walks you know he's seeing
it well when he's seeing it well
that's when especially from the left
side he's going to start taking it out
three-run lead heading into the knights
it becomes a safe situation for liam
hendricks
on for the 21st time he's 10 of 12 and
save opportunities the era is a good one
at 237.
[Applause]
galvez up the ladder third base side
moncada leaves it for tim and that will
do it
six up six down for the bullpen couple
of home runs and a win
well look the ariel's made it a whole
lot closer than you would want but then
the offense put it away late and with
liam hendricks in a clean inning when
his stuff looks like it did today he's
going to save a bunch of them